j'aimerais tant voler de mes propres
ailes
j à quelqu'un je veux tout ce que je
n'ai pas il faut que je vous vois je
voudrais que ma vie joue celle qu'on
attendait ça n'a jamais rien dit ravi
trick
ce monde est bien trop petit pour moi
[Musique]
belle ma chérie tu es tellement en
avance sur ton temps
et c'est un tout petit village tué la
créature la plus somptueuse de tout
l'univers
personne n'est digne de toi les gens
l'esprit étroit voilà tout
mais un village les plus sûrs qu'une
ville
[Musique]
je suis venu chercher mon père votre
père et enfants leur il faut que je vous
vois
j'ai pas pu je te le promets regarde une
jeune fille qui a du sens coucou ou
paris mais évidemment il ne fait même
plus ça
je suis ravie de faire votre
connaissance vous voulez voir ce que je
sais faire
qu'arrivera-t-il quand le dernier
pétales tombe à 2 mètres demeurera une
bête pour toujours nous devient trop de
la camelote
il faut que vous mettiez tâchez de vous
lever
[Musique]
si c'est bien elle qui doit rompre le
sort vous devez enfin apprendre à aimer
[Musique]
avez-vous réellement lu tous ses livres
pas tous certains sont encore
la peine
[Musique]